En este video vamos a intentar comprender
los límites de las funciones compuestas,
o al menos una forma de pensar sobre los límites
de las funciones compuestas, y, en particular,
vamos a pensar en cómo encontrar el límite cuando
x se acerca a a de f(g(x)), y vamos a ver que, bajo
ciertas circunstancias, esto será igual a f ( lim
x → a g(x)). Y seguro te estás preguntando ¿cuáles
son esas circunstancias? Bueno, esto será cierto
si y sólo si se cumplen dos cosas: en primer
lugar, este límite debe existir, el límite cuando
x → a g(x) debe existir; en segundo lugar, se
debe cumplir que la función f sea continua en este
punto y f es continua en L. Así que veamos algunos
ejemplos en donde trataremos de aplicar esta idea.
A ver si es posible. Aquí tengo dos funciones que
están representadas gráficamente: en el lado
izquierdo tenemos la función f y en el lado
derecho tenemos la función g. Primero averigüemos
cuál es el límite cuando x → -3 f(g(x)). Pausa
este video y primero trata de aplicar el teorema,
y si puedes aplicarlo trata de calcular el límite.
Entonces, lo primero que debemos ver es
si se puede aplicar el teorema. Entonces,
en primer lugar, si tuviéramos que encontrar el
límite cuando x → -3 (g(x)), ¿cuál sería? Bueno,
cuando nos acercamos a -3 desde la derecha parece
que la función está en 3, y cuando nos acercamos a
-3 desde la izquierda parece que nuestra función
está en 3. Así que todo indica que este límite
es 3; aunque el valor de g en -3 es -2, pero es
un punto de discontinuidad: al acercarnos a él
desde cualquier lado, el valor de la función
es 3; entonces, esto va a ser 3. Sí existe, y,
por lo tanto, cumplimos con esa primera condición.
Ahora, la segunda pregunta es ¿nuestra función f
es continua en este límite?, ¿es continua en 3?
Bueno, cuando x = 3, sí, parece que en ese punto
la función definitivamente es continua, por lo que
podemos decir que este límite va a ser igual a f
(lim x→ -3 g(x)). Cierro paréntesis, y sabemos
que esto es igual a 3 y que f(3 ) = -1. Así que
esto cumplió las condiciones para este teorema y
pudimos usar el teorema para resolver este límite.